[Musique]
tout
vous cherchez une façons d'apprêter les
champignons portobello le chef pascal
lafon nous le propose en carpaccio
d'abord on retire les lamelles puis on
fait de minces tranches puis ce qu'on a
fait on les prend on l'est on les envoie
dans notre salle à 10 avec une petite
note pépins de raisin vous voyez qu'une
huile d'olive donc on veut quelque chose
de plus parfumé vinaigre si peu importe
unique de riz donc le vinaigre va
beaucoup courir le champignon un peu de
sel et on mélange simplement niveau
délicatement parce que très très très
fragile et précieux enregistre d'avc
[Musique]
calculez cinq à six tranches par convive
pour ce carpaccio original et plein de
fraîcheur